welcome back joining us now a guy who
made a great impact for the los angeles
rams as a rookie in 2020 he was a second
round pick out of florida state he's
running back cam akers cam how are you
man
yeah i'm doing good how you doing we're
doing great it was a fairly uneventful
weekend for the los angeles rams nothing
happened on saturday night that would
cause anyone to
pay any attention to the team how did
you find out about the news that there
was a fairly significant trait of
quarterbacks that was going to happen
i just found same way everybody else
espn
notification to my phone you know uh it
popped up and i was like wow
you know kind of caught me off guard uh
me and jg
uh built a great relationship you know
throughout year one so
i wasn't really expecting them to leave
i didn't know but yeah i didn't know
what was going on
and uh but when that did happen
first thing that came to the thought of
my mind was it's a business you know mom
so
you got to take if you talk to have you
talked to jared since it happened
uh i haven't yet but i just wanted to
kind of give him some time you know kind
of let
everything die down i kind of know i
know everything was kind of crazy for
him but being crazy for him but
i said i was going to give him a call
though what what's your
what's like i know you didn't get to see
matt stafford and the lions in person
today
or this year you know your rookie year
but what what's your thoughts and
impression on him just seeing him on tv
oh he's a big arm you know that's first
and foremost big arm
i can tell he wants to win you know more
than anything else
he got the desire to win um and a lot
a lot of people on that team out there
so he'll just fit right in
yeah i mean it seems that way that's why
i want to ask you next i mean
first impression when you saw aaron
donald in person
and then when you got on the practice
field i just i gotta ask you about him
when i saw him i was like damn big you
know
[Laughter]
hey but uh he wasn't as tall as i
thought but
obviously that don't make a difference
so when when
when it come to a.d and the first time i
practiced against him
it was just like every time he was back
he was in the backfield
you know every play and that wasn't just
the first time i practiced against note
every time
for the whole year and um you realize
that's why he goes out on sunday and
does what he does
uh that's a great representation and a
great example to
have every day to look at
cam i've even heard from gm les sneed
that
the rams can't even do a walk through
when aaron donald's around that he blows
it up
even when everybody's supposed to be
just you know going through the motions
easily
yeah he will uh he's gonna get his work
that's the way you know
he's gonna get his work get his looks uh
as you should as he should you know he
pays off
that's a grown man though that's a grown
man
have you gotten the full force of a hit
from aaron donald at any of the
practices this year
yeah i'm sure he would say i haven't i'm
sure he would say i ain't like well on
full force he just cheat off on me you
know but
he didn't talk you know he talked to me
uh in a scrimmage
but it was kind of weird because he told
me he was like i'm gonna make you fumble
he told me that two days before
and he made me fumble
you got a lot you got a lot of
personalities
and i played for a coach in john gruden
that's a lot like
your coach i mean you know your coach is
like john gruden jr
just again i i hate to do it to you but
like that
first impression of mcveigh not only
when you met him
but when he got up there and started
installing plays like what were you
thinking to yourself
uh like a rocket you know he's got a
rocky y'all he's got energy he's always
upbeat up tempo
uh you know it's never like a dull
moment with coach mcveigh
and just he's a genius like he's smart
you know he's real smart
he knows uh he knows the game he knows
game well
and uh you can you can see it and the
way he coaches his team
uh he demands uh a lot of a lot of
respect and a lot of
a lot of hard work a lot of
accountability you know out of us so
did you find the offense like
overwhelming or what was it like for you
to make the adjustment to like a mcvay
offense
coming from florida state uh i wouldn't
i didn't find it overwhelming you know i
just found it
it's just a process you know yeah i just
felt
saw it as a process and as an
opportunity to learn you know
coming in i knew it was gonna be a
learning curve i knew it was gonna be i
wasn't gonna know
everything coming in uh due to
lack of um kovic you know not allowing
us to be here
how we were supposed to soldier knowing
that
understanding and still being able to
come in um
and learn it and be effective that was
my whole goal
another guy who went to florida state
dalvin cook went to minnesota and became
the guy
at the tailback position the rams
seemingly
cam have wanted to have two or three
guys sharing the load
are you kind of hoping that over time as
they see what you can do
you'll get to be more like dalvin is in
minnesota
um
it's a hard question man uh
as long as i just take advantage of my
opportunity you know
i wouldn't say i'm like yeah i wouldn't
say i got a problem with a committee or
whatever you know or
i wouldn't don't have problem with being
a man you know whatever i'm in is what
i'm in
you had a huge game best of the season
on that thursday night against the new
england patriots with 171 rushing yards
you were the offensive player of the
week for the nfc that week
when do you know in a game like that
where you're having that kind of
performance when does it click for you
that this is my night and this is going
to be a big performance for me
uh you know from really
the first time you touched the ball you
know the first two or three times
uh based on the the
you know based on the plays that you
make within the first two or three times
you touch the ball and
breaking loose if you you you you know
obviously that's not always the case
because that running back you could
get point two you can run about two for
two yards
twelve times in the thirteenth time
break for 79
70 80 yards so you know uh
yeah i i guess it's safe to say you
don't really know you know you don't
really know
you just playing but somebody like me
happened at any time what i
i mean i know we're going gonna talk
about panini here in a second
but i mean other than that that's
catching my attention here
i mean what's that say on your deck
what's that necklace right there i gotta
look at
some of that new money bling bling there
what's that say there they
say sit boy and what's that mean
miss i'm from mississippi so i'm gonna
sit back so that's a miss
gotcha okay you gotta keep me up man i'm
getting old i'm a 40 year old dad i'm
not real cool with all the lingo and
stuff
that that a that a after the draft or
after the season purchase when did you
decide to do that
oh man again he wanted to know a lot of
detail
oh i want to know all the goods where
are you spending all that new money
man it was after the draft after the
draft
good for you all right all right now
you're you're done i want to ask you you
got to play the bucks right the team
that's representing the nfc in the super
bowl
i'd love to know just you know your
thoughts
about them and what stood out to you on
that monday night football game that of
course has gotten them here
uh those other resilient guys you know
those guys come out and give you
everything they got every play
uh every snap every game so
um you just gotta bring your a game
every time you play them you know
they got the pieces they got the big
they got the big names you know
and they got the role player so uh you
got to come out and you got to put your
best foot forward every time you play
those guys
cam you got the great panini background
tell us what you have going on with them
man we signed up some some cards some
panini cards doing a little photo shoot
man
just uh just just enjoying it just
enjoying it
i see that hashtag who do you collect
who do you collect cam
uh i haven't started collecting yet but
uh
probably some like friends you know i
probably won't get you want to get out
of my friend's car
that's gonna lead you know everybody
that you know
everybody i know but i will start
collecting them
okay last thing go ahead oh sorry go
ahead i was gonna
i wanted to ask him about an ex-teammate
well not an ex-teammate but an alumni
and one of my favorite players on your
team because you seem quiet and cool and
reserved
but what about my man big mouth jalen
ramsay
talk about him and like just what he
does for the locker room and
bringing energy every day
uh generally is everything you just said
that dude
he's a dog you know he's a dog every day
he's a dog every you know that's just
the way he go about living you know
uh he's gonna come to work every day
he's gonna go to work he come to work to
go to work
you know he's gonna work hard he's gonna
prepare
and on sundays he's gonna lock up
everybody best receiver
that we know is gonna happen we know
that's gonna happen so
every sunday he's out there he's locking
up everybody best to see
you the man said you the man said boy
congratulations on the great rookie
season all the best moving forward we
look forward to talking to you again
down the road
appreciate it thank y'all
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports